tripod class you won't even be able to
be mad at me because you'll see I'm
being very fair Eddie was I not being
there I was being fair and she took my
and she tried manipulating it to go for
her cup following is she talking about
the clips what is she saying here she's
talking about the show where she
embarrassed herself which she would not
have to manipulate you it's two and a
half hours unedited some people see I
don't know it was like I'm trying to
remember her show exactly I remember
it's hard because that's why I think
we're gonna edit it in or something but
basically what happened was she came on
the show and she told this story about
her like her husband at the time she
left him because he might cheat like he
said I might cheat and then it was like
oh we're not together now but we'll be
together later my child's fine and then
she was saying how she was not a
feminine woman then but she's a feminine
woman now and I said well how like if
you're a feminine woman like what have
you done because there's this it's not
just her like a lot of times girls come
on the show and they think it's just
them that I'm basing these conclusions
on but there's a whole group of like
YouTubers that they're like femininity
coaches or they talk about being
feminine and they've done no work they
just say they're feminine one day
they're like oh I'm feminine now and I'm
like okay well have you been in a
relationship where that guy will co-sign
that you're feminine and you've been
practicing it right have you been
learning to cook like what specifically
have you done like you still work you
just watched a few YouTube videos I
think the thing that stood out was she
started off talking and talking and
talking and talking and talking and then
suddenly she mentioned she had a child
yeah that's a bombshell he didn't like
the way she did that the way it switched
because we're all giving her advice as a
single married woman and then all of a
sudden it was like and my child she sort
of slipped that she had a child in there
and then the whole conversation changed
and she didn't like him yeah and then um
so Carnival is like a crazy Festival
here right and you saw the video I did
and so she talked about and I think
she's going to talk about this she
talked about how she went to she went to
Carnival which at first it was like
you're a single woman but how are you
traditional and you're at carnival right
and I don't claim to be like the epitome
of traditional women however like I only
went to Carnival to do interviews and
like I'm sorry the women that I know
that are the most feminine and the most
traditional you could not oh my God my
dog
um you could not not too many Housewives
at a carnival no no but the thing is is
that for Pearl it was like a culture
shock but women married women do codes
of Carnival traditional women they do go
to Carnival but what they do is that
they make sure if you're going to go to
Carnival you there's two days to go to
Carnival there's children's day and
there's the adults day so if I'm going
to take a child if I'm going to go to a
carnival by myself as a married woman I
would either go with my man on a Monday
or unless you're in a band you'd go on a
Sunday so you do take children on a
Sunday but you get them home before
bedtime yeah I have a sneaking suspicion
she didn't bring her kid to the kids day
one well she comes to just she
contradicted herself and that's what
happened like she would tell these
stories and then later like I would be
like okay this doesn't make sense but
like like that's what would happen is
she because I was listening and then
later she would say things that kind of
like contradicted herself yeah and then
I would be like okay I'm just being real
with you you hear I didn't make you say
this this is based on the words that
came out of your mouth this isn't making
sense and then she's like you
manipulated me but the thing is like
modern women are so used to not having
pushback for anything that they don't
even realize how delusional they sound
like she I bet you she has no idea she
talks for 60 70 of a podcast with 10
people on it you'd be surprised
she says it on him that she talked much
she thanked you for giving her all that
time on the show oh okay let's see so
her men can be like yeah that girl's
chatting [__] yo man I don't mean like
putting what you're saying because
that's a lie before we use if you watch
the full podcast you will see nothing
was clipped she wish it was clipped to
make her look good but enough it was
clipped and even after it was clipped
but I always say to people that when you
see things like this go and watch the
whole podcast before you make a decision
based on five minutes did you say okay
for example for example if I say when I
go out on the streets men approach me
right does she look approachable and
then she said that men will grab in
Morocco but she actually said it next to
Moroccan who pulled her up about it
because the men weren't grabbing her the
men were approaching her because she's
in a tourist area is obviously she
looked like that then she switched and
said even when I go home to India but
obviously that twist traditional look at
her Indian women do not expose
themselves like that when you go to
Morocco people go to Morocco as tourists
but if you there's some places you go to
where it's safer and it's more tradition
for women to cover yourself up if you
look at some of the um female reporters
when they go certain places they will
put on the scarf they will cover up
themselves I'm not saying all men I'm
saying men I get more approach she might
not get approached the way I get
approached yeah because you're so out of
shape girl they might not find her
attractive many reasons yeah what are
the reasons Phil give us a reason you're
not attractive Phil
one of the reasons is not because you're
away you'll find me unattracted
attractive but her beautiful
she knows that I'm now me too me tooing
all men I'm saying that all men harass
me I'm not saying we always talk in the
majority she didn't say that some men
harass her she said all men harass her I
mean she's she's casting a vision for
society where she can't even go in
public yes she can't even go in public
and that that was the point I was making
was she was saying like everywhere I go
these people approach me and I'm like
you realize like and I I don't remember
off the top of my head but I believe I
said something along the lines of like
this is why men will say you're me
tooing everyone because because you're
you're casting a certain light on men
and I'm just saying that's a shitty way
to look at men I agree and I don't I
don't think like I wouldn't want to be
Associated if they said oh I can't go
anywhere like women are always touching
me like like that that's a shitty light
on woman yeah and I just think like you
need to be careful about the things that
you say yeah and especially if you're
going to generalize about a group of
people and I I really wish I knew the
time stamps of that video because I'd
like to pull it up but we can we could
go back to it later is this a clip
there's many Clips
did you shout out to my content team in
Nigeria yeah shout out Chris Shout Out
Chris
he pulls lots of clips from you mean you
have ethnic people doing your videos
yeah yeah oh wow yeah yeah doesn't
matter obviously to us
did she say you're saying all manner
says she said she then labeled it this
woman is me doing all men on what on a
thumbnail yes YouTube
If I know I don't like if someone came
on my podcast I know I'm doing a genuine
podcast by the way she hasn't got a
podcast yet I will not manipulate for
clickbait I don't do that wait she
doesn't have a podcast no she says she's
gonna have one oh
podcast no she doesn't the other girl
has she will say later on oh yeah
I would say anyone that comes I love I
love people that have never done the job
and just think they can do it better
they're really Pleasant
let me let me go up to Jeff Bezos and
tell him how to run Amazon but the thing
is what she doesn't realize that she's
got the perfect pod whatever you say for
us in our thumbnails we'll just Elevate
and we might of course for example when
you came in and said your dad had two
wives yeah we can we said oh your dad
had two wives because that's what you
said yeah we didn't say like this woman
Advocates that every man should have
exactly is that he's spinning exactly
yeah
there's only one aspect to it the other
important bit is what you actually see
and that's yeah and that's what I said
to you that it's important as a
podcaster it's a skill a lot of people
think just come here and talk yeah it's
your ability to control The Narrative of
the conversation
but also and again maybe this is where
the cultural differences are when it
comes to even like me traveling as an
Asian woman they don't see me as my
British passport they see me as an Asian
woman if I go to Dubai they see me as a
Bangladeshi woman and they will take
advantage of that thinking I'm a
Bangladeshi woman it's just interesting
um because I know a couple people from
those countries and they don't actually
have the same views as you
grew up in the like like um you said
well I think you said Morocco yeah
majority I'll say this the context on in
which this happened you were on holiday
right you're right about the pillow
I've noticed I'm Banning them from the
show and you're saying that people
grabbed you what was the context of that
group no I'm not saying that they're
constantly grabbing this approach a
constantly trying to talk yeah is
changing yeah
you can be quite shy and introvert me
personally I'm very very shy but when
you are in a situation where you feel
comfortable you can come out of your
shell and with some guys you know with
some girls they can come out their shell
whereas other women have made them feel
no you stay shy because women
I don't think that I think guys will
approach you if they feel good about
themselves so if they feel like they're
you know put pushing gym or whatever
that to build their own self-confidence
I I know guys that feel good about
themselves like they're like yeah I'm
good looking I go to the gym you know
I'm a nice person and he won't approach
a girl but he'll look at a girl and be
like no I won't approach her because we
we like or that girl looks so good and
this is the definitely femininity I
think a lot more women are masculine
because back in the day women would
signal and even when we had kit on the
other day he he educates women yeah he
educates women how to signal to allow a
man to to look comfortable enough to get
um to approach again
maybe the problem is men aren't actually
looking for women's signal before
they're approaching so when a girl is
now calling Park Patrol is because she's
not signaled to you she's not showed you
she's any interest in you don't know
what her relationship status is and
maybe wait for the cues for a woman
can I say this I think women embody
masculinity more now
no no but look at the instructions okay
you notice she's trying to talk you
interrupt she's trying to talk you and
her every single time I don't know if
anyone else uses tfl regularly maybe I'm
poor but you know go on the tube you see
the advert I um stare and harassment
it puts men on edge yeah reportedly
there's a phone number
yeah
to like countries where there isn't that
a lot of men take advantage so it's not
these aren't put in there for women do
the majority of men are the majority of
men the men you're describing sorry
majority of men Dominion describing so
the meaning you're saying that take
advantage is that the country like where
this isn't the social Norm just answer
the question where you have to but is
that the majority of men sorry is that
do you so the majority of yeah go on do
you think the majority of men are doing
that in those countries in those
countries what going up to women
unsolicited yeah 100 normal okay boom
majority amen
boom
the majority of men approach majority
much better she me too the majority of
men is that Kobe Kobe is that
is that is that much better than all men
it's not taken out of context at all I
mean you could literally just put quote
majority of men end quote in developing
countries or sex offenders that's what
she's saying you know what you know what
hold up hold up I'm gonna
Zariah if you're watching this I'm gonna
switch it for you I'm gonna put
the majority just to make it a little
more accurate maybe I see where you're
coming from yeah maybe I see where she's
going the majority of men you're right
so she's like there's like a 10 of men
that are just so socially anxious they
won't approach anybody the other 90 are
all vicious yep vile you know she is me
too and the thing is how many times how
many times is that question asked how
many times to get to the answer Yeah
Eddie asks the question you ask the
question I'm sure idiots a couple of
times you asked a couple of times before
she actually came up with an answer